as people know you and custom
a uh trained young Mike
Tyson and the interaction there U
between the three of you led to the
three of you parting
ways given your value for loyalty can
you tell the full story of uh what led
up to this and
maybe the pain you felt
from
that I it was if I guess it was the
second time in my life I felt
betrayed um the first time was
when I
um I was whatever young
17 and I got
arrested I was with all these older guys
tough guys whatever
and um
supposedly and uh the detectives
separated us that's what they do and um
you know they they asked me who did
whatever who's gun this that you know
all that the particulars of obviously
what we did and you know it was me and
um they said you sure you don't want to
change that you don't want to because
your friends changed it and and these
cops they nasty but they were cops they
were the way you know you're going to
wind up in Rikers with and they're going
to be doing this to you and I won't even
say that things because then why say
them you know figure it out but you know
they're trying to get what they're
trying to get and you know you want to
change it and um
no and but I felt very betrayed you know
yeah and um especially when I was
standing in the in the cell in rikus
looking at the airplanes leave luati
airport and then hoping I was on one you
know I was making like a deal with God
that let me be on one of those planes
and let it crash I'll take a shot was
part of you proud that you didn't give
up your friends no because I didn't
understand what proud was I didn't
understand nothing I just understood
that um rules are rules you're just
loyal and that's it I didn't even know
there was an option I didn't think there
I know the cops said you could do this
but that there was no option my father
never had an
option but the Betrayal the private
betrayal was like and so when
CU we were Partners me and cus yeah CZ
was
retired this stupid kid goes up there
and all of a sudden I start training
Fighters first I won the gloves cuz put
me in the gloves I won the gloves that
had injury whatever but bottom line is I
I still want to fight I want to turn pro
I want to fight that was the plan and
um and cuz had a different
plan cuz cuz was like you can't and he
had it set up a little bit whatever
without getting into it hey he did me a
favor and I I'd like to think he knew he
was doing me a favor and you know what I
do think he was he was doing himself a
little bit one too but but he was doing
for the great of course because he
believed in this thing of boxing he he
believed that it changed lives he
believed that it was worthwhile he
believed that there was a power to it
beyond the left hook the big picture of
box yeah he believed in it yeah he
believed that To Be A Champion you had
to be special you had to be smart you
had to have character you had that you
had to be a better person and that you
couldn't make a champion if you didn't
make him a better person first and and
that that this you know this could
strengthen people the the sport could
strengthen people in those ways so
he he was married to it and he he was
old and he needed there was no one in
the gym it was
empty and it was above a police station
which was crazy and he needed an air to
the throne he needed to pass it on to
someone and he saw something and all of
a sudden he said he saw that my career
as a box was less important than having
me become his air to the Drone and
become his trainer his man his guy to
continue that we could do a lot more for
him and for for for everyone not just
for him but for everyone it was more
like to keep it going like it couldn't
die it couldn't die and becausein was
afraid to it would die with him and he
committed his whole life to it he didn't
get married because of boxing so he
didn't so he saw me as as you know the
the little bit of you know the seed to
plant for for more
things to grow before that plant died
and so he all of a sudden he say he
can't fight and I had people tell me
that I could go somewhere else and fight
and I
could but I couldn't right because I'd
be disloyal loyalty is everything yeah
so I couldn't leave CZ yeah and he kind
of knew that and and so you know I
couldn't leave him and he said you have
an ability to teach he said knowledge
means nothing
he said see these pranica he had pran
pranica encyclopedia uh the whole set in
in our library he said you see these
yeah I see them all the knowledge of the
world whatever uh is in these all right
means nothing if you don't have somebody
to convey it to people otherwise it just
sits on a bookshelf it looks good
because go you have the ability to
convey knowledge to people you're a
teacher you were born to be a teacher
you'd lessen Yourself by only being a
champion fighter because you'd only take
care of one person you could take care
of all kinds of people and you could do
this and you could do that and you could
do this so we go on this Venture took a
minute cuz I didn't believe him at first
but finally we I am I'm there I'm
training
Fighters and then he he gets me to buy
in and I I was a teacher and I start
teaching these kids and there's no one
in the gym it's dead and all of a sudden
there's 10 kids 15 20 25 30 35 40 45 cat
skill boxing club which was never there
now it's there and I'm training Fighters
I'm taking down to South Bronx to get
experience one of his former Fighters
NOS quas down the South Bronx I'm taking
down there to get smokers to get fights
when they're ready after I'm wearing out
dungar I'm getting holes of my dung I
was fashionable before it was
fashionable to have holes of my dungar
I could have made a lot of money with
that because I was on my knees with
these little kids 9 years old 10 years
old 8 years old 10 12 13 14 all these
kids and and I'm teaching and I'm
building a gym and cuz only came once a
week because he was semi-retired you
know and and he's and when he would come
once a week he knew he couldn't give me
money but he gave me more than money he
gave me praise mhm and he said look what
Atlas is doing he's creating chions and
I was like wow yeah wow I'm I'm doing
good and and and then all of a sudden
after four years of that because I was
up there seven years eight years eight
years after about three and a half four
years of that we get a phone call that
they got this kid in prison and try on
Prison uh from one of the guys that knew
C Matt Baranski uh and and there's a
state there's a correction officer named
Bobby Stewart who used to box and cuz
had helped him out a little bit a little
bit and um and they knew we had this gym
now that was really starting to become
something because we were winning
tournaments and everything else the go
we got this kid Mike Tyson he he's he's
12 years old he's 190 pounds he's a mess
but Bobby Stewart got involved with him
uh you know the the former fighter and
he's taking a liking to it and now where
he didn't behave at all and he didn't
listen to anyone now he's listening
because Bobby's got a carrot and the it
is H he teacher boxing and now he he's
at the point now where we we want you to
take a look you and Teddy all right
bring him down what what did you think
when you first saw Mike T well I I want
to I want to see his birth certificate
because he 190 pounds 12 years old and
all solid yeah um you know really but
yeah just physically just as a physical
specimen and and big gu yeah and
listen cuz was right I was a teacher he
was right and he was testing me even
that day he said what do you think so I
said well we ain't going to know nothing
in the bag who the freak cares about
that he knocked the bag down we got to
put him in with uh we got no one to put
him in that way I didn't have anyone
that way we got to test them everyone's
got to be tested and um so you got to
put them in responsibly but let's put
them in just respond but let put him in
with Bobby Stewart former Prof fighter
had 14 Prof fights smaller than Tyson uh
he was when he was fighting he was 175
but still he's 28 years old Tyson's 12
come on and and he'll work with him
right so we do we put him Tyson he
recognized the moment he understood this
was an audition this was a chance you
know this was that TV show change your
life and he understood that if he passed
the audition he could change possibly
change his life he wasn't sure what how
could he be sure what exactly but it was
better than what he had and so he was on
all dis so he wanted he innately
understood what we would want to see
ferociousness
toughness uh character uh desire you
know and of course ability well we saw
the ability power speed but it was it
was unbridled it was untaught it was it
was raw he didn't know really much at
all um at all but
we saw that but he wanted to show more
he knew that wasn't enough again in Nate
intelligence he he had to show desire he
had to show toughness and so I was being
responsible after two rounds that's
enough normally I don't put a guy into
box until maybe four months five months
6 Months 8 months 10 it depends what it
takes to learn on the floor before it's
responsible to put him in the ring to to
actually take on uh incoming real live
show
instead of blanks yeah and so normally I
wouldn't have him in and I knew after
today he wouldn't be in the ring again
if I trained him I would teach him first
and then he'd get back in in a few
months but for this day it was the only
way it's kind of like I used to make
this analogy and cus loved it I he said
what's trading a fighter what do you
what do you look for trading a fighter
Teddy you know he asked me this
ridiculous question just to test me and
and I say it's like going to Macy's
he loved it I said it's like I said it's
like go to Macy's window Christ he goes
what do you mean Macy's window you know
cuz was like boom boom boom so what do
you mean Macy's window oh you go to
Macy's window and they get the window
with everything you want to see
everything in there it looks great oh
everything and yeah and then what well
then you ask what's in the warehouse and
they tell you
nothing yeah and then cuz says that's it
that's a trainer yeah and I wanted to
see what was in the warehouse
because I saw what was in the Macy's
window I saw the power I saw the speed
so he goes two rounds and he gets a
bloody nose here's the weird thing not
weird very telling we knew what we were
doing not bragging but we knew what we
were doing because he got a bloody nose
because he got
hit after that Bloody he never got
another bloody nose you know why he
didn't get hit cuz he learned he was
still strong but he was smarter now
anyway he goes two rounds and I saw and
I'm responsible because if he goes more
it's not responsible I saw what I needed
to say I saw speed I saw power I saw
athleticism and I saw I didn't believe
him I thought he was lying to me I'm
just telling you I I thought he was
lying trying to act tough when he wasn't
really feeling tough it didn't matter
cuz questioned me on it afterwards what
did you say and when I said he goes
young Master you know again he wasn't
paying me money so he had to give me
something right and and that was better
than that was currency young master I'm
Master whoa you know young Master you
know what I mean like I felt like that
guy Kung Fu you know like in the movie
like Kung Fu grasshopper when you're
ready when you could take this out of my
hand you can leave and that's powerful
yeah it was it worked cuz knew how to
work me and he did and and it worked and
and so but you know what I didn't mind
being worked I kind of knew I was being
shuffled a little bit well you're making
it sound a little bit negative but it's
also extremely positive that's a teacher
instilling wisdom into you that you
carried forward and impacted a lot of
people yeah CU got the job done but he
did it his way and and he did it for a
lot of a myriad of reasons and but at
the end of the day it was all good and I
I just had to understand that eventually
uh later on but and you do the same you
do things your way and carry some of him
in you some of your father in you yeah
that day you know that day was funny
because when C said what did you see
Teddy when him after two rounds I got up
in the ring I knew I was going to train
him obviously we weren't going to say no
and he still had about four months to
serve and we were going to work it out
yeah
and when I got up on a ring apron that's
my gym I'm the boss you know people
later on in life called me a dictator
you know what I said yeah you're right I
didn't deny people thought you you you
mean I'm right yeah I'm a dictator I'm a
trainer I'm the boss I'm in charge if I
you wouldn't be here if I wasn't what
the freak you need me for if I'm not
freaking in charge you idiot yeah yeah
damn right what do you think it's a it's
a shed responsibility no it's my
responsibility that's why you're here
yeah I am in charge and you shouldn't be
here if you don't understand that so I
get up there and I know that I'm going
to be training them I got to show them
who the boss is MH you know I'm being
really Frank about this so I get up
there say that's it out yeah no no you
know this is Ty no let me go I want to
do another round I want to do another I
want I said out did you hear what I said
because I knew that you know he was
going to test me he testing me I I said
I said get out MH he got out but were
you impressed with the fact that you
want to keep going or not yes and I
recognized what it really was so cus
asked me what was that MH C know what
the young Master saw so God said what
was
that I said it was
um it was an act he goes you saw
that did he really want to go I said no
I said he didn't really want to go but
he knew that we want him to go and he
made himself ready to go in order to
satisfy and that's just as good because
said damn right it's just as good all
that matters was not not not how he got
there but that he got there yeah that's
all that matters that he got there that
he got to the place to act like a
fighter to to do what we want him to do
to be ready to persevere to go beyond
the Comfort level to do another round he
didn't want to damn righty didn't want
to but he knew we want him to and he
knew in order to pass the test he had to
do it MH and he said you're right he
goes now it's going to be your job
to teach him to make him a fighter that
don't get bloody noses that don't get
hit and we'll get to that place without
being
coerced to get there to get to that
place on his
own instead of using the things that he
had to use to get to that place today
those things are not going to be
available one day when you and listen to
this you talk about a man being
prophetic CU was pretty good
you talk about man being on a job on a
money Lex he says how do you think he
finishes the sent he goes because
someday you because you know you're
going to have to make sure that he
learns these things because you know he
he'll be your first heavyweight
champ what did you just say he's 12
years old yeah yeah he he's been
arrested 30 times yeah he's getting out
of jail out of you know Juvenile
Detention try on
um he's a mess in a lot of ways there's
a lot of things we find out later a lot
of problems weaknesses start he goes and
you that's part of your job that'll be
part of your job and but he really said
that he and then then he turned to him
he goes you want to come live with us
young man you want to be your
fighter yes even that C said to me later
what do you think about that I said he a
the way he said yes the yeah the way he
said yes yes sir yeah he said what do
you think about that and we're talking I
said ain't going to be that polite in a
little while down the road again he knew
that that's what he felt that he needed
to to project himself as to to present
himself as to to get to where he want to
get to he because you yeah yeah did you
see what cus was seeing in terms of the
heavyweight champion of the world no
again be easiest answer would be yes
Teddy Teddy Alis genius wow wow Teddy
wow no no no no but again it was my job
yeah and I just I my job it was simple
simpler than cusses cus Knew Too Much I
knew nothing I just knew you know rud of
box and I knew what it took to be a
fighter and and how to execute it the
steps of executing it so I took those
steps the the the rest of it you get
blurred by those other things I wasn't
blurred by those other things I it was
it was just get him in the
gym make them mentally stronger make
them face things and teach them how to
slip
punches and and create holes and fill
those freaking holes with devastating
punches this is cuss and what are you
going to do I'm going to teach him to
fill holes and fill them with punches
with bad intentions yeah and and that
became the Monica yeah and then Tyson
would say that I'm throwing punches with
bad intentions yes you are and um
you know how do you make it mentally
tougher so that part of the job the you
said the don't get a bloody nose but the
part of the job where makes it mentally
tougher how do you do that most
important part of the job to make him
face things yeah make him face where he
lying to himself where he's submitting
what if we start this conversation with
submission yeah submit less yeah submit
less submit less every day submit less
cuz I only come to the gym once in a
while and if I had him spawn he would
come because that was his that was his
project that was the heavyweight now he
came you know put life in cuz cuz had
life he he was losing a little life but
that made the light bulb bright again it
did and it was great to see I felt proud
of that I felt connected to that and
that's why when when when it all went
bad and CZ took the side that the only
side he could take the side of the next
heavyweight champion of the world but he
but he left me his partner the young
master and
of the second time I get betrayed and
I'm
like for a while I thought everything C
taught me said to me was a liar I didn't
want to be any part of it anymore until
I got a little more mature and I got a
little past
that where I was able to
understand I was able to
understand that
just because
sobody that you perceived as great in
every area is you find to be weak in
certain
areas doesn't
mean that they can't still be what they
want to
you it's it's something
that it's something that can be
understood or
forgiven it's hard it's hard to get to
that place and forgive somebody in that
kind of way that I felt betrayed because
cuz told me the most important thing was
loyalty cuz told me he loved me because
I was L cuz cuz told people that the
reason that he went to court was because
I didn't give up anybody even though it
meant put me in the risk of going to
jail for 10 years and he and cuz felt
that he admired those traits and so I
assumed that he he would show know the
same traits and he took a
deal he took a deal he took a deal he he
he signed the papers that those that
those so-called fine signed you know he
he he took a deal to to you
know to to have the future Heavyweight
Championship turned out uh and and to
let me you know to let me go to sign the
deal to to let me take you know take the
weight for people who don't
know uh Mike was inappropriate with a
young girl and you pulled the gun on
him I don't know if there's deeper
things to say about that situation no
but why do you think hus made the
decision to cut you off from both Mike
Tyson and from C Cato like to break that
when he valued loyalty so I served my
purpose I got him to the way he needed
to get
um brought life back in the gym if I
wasn't in the gym at that particular
time Tyson never would have been in the
gym there would have been no gym to
bring him to when they called up and
made that phone call to bring them to
the gym there would have been no
activity there would have been no boxing
program there would have been you know
no trainer training him 247 the way I
was where C wasn't capable of doing that
at that point in his life yeah but then
again it's not poor Teddy I get the
benefit of a career I get the benefit of
knowledge I get the benefit of a life I
get the benefit of learning of of
becoming hopefully a better person um I
got the benefit of being betrayed again
um but that's a hell of a statement
right there I don't know what the
benefit of that
is you can learn to forgive
weakness you
know when you realize
how
how easy it is to be
weak and and when you realize that
somebody asked me how did you get to the
point where you you could forgive right
it's a pretty good question pretty
simple pretty basic pretty important
right and I didn't I didn't understand I
understood but I did understand
immediately for
me I said how can I not forgive
somebody it becomes easier to learn how
to
forgive when you're still trying to
forgive
yourself when you're still in the
process of trying to forgive yourself
for all your own inherent
weaknesses and betrayals of people like
my
father in different ways that we forget
very easily because it's
handy and it's a way of
surviving it's a lot easier to to figure
it out rationalize it to to to to find
forgiveness when you realize that you
still haven't figured out completely how
to forgive
yourself I'm still trying to figure that
out and
um so that helped me figure out how to
forgive
cus because to figure out how to forgive
me I had to understood why I did these
things where the where the weaknesses
came from where the selfishness came
from where the convenience came from
that they really
existed but they didn't exist for
malice they existed for me not being
prepared to understand that I could be
stronger to want to be stronger and then
I looked at cus he wanted to be stronger
but he got to a point in life where he
had been strong for a lot of his life he
was strong with me he was strong with a
lot of things in his life and does
everyone deserve a pass in
life
where he got he got to a place where
everything was in one basket the basket
of boxing he once told me that he never
got married because it would be it would
been selfish to a woman to have gotten
married when his whole life was boxing
that he couldn't give to a kid he
couldn't give to
he could and and then I thought about it
he had no money really and Jim Jacobs
and Bill Cayton took care of the bills
so he didn't really need money that way
but the one what was the payoff for that
kind of life that kind of commitment
that kind of sacrifice really what was
the
payoff the
payoff was to have
Champions to have a champion that would
keep your name alive you know that word
legacy like what does it mean sometimes
it's it's just a word sometimes it's
it's more than a word it it's it's it's
a
reprieve it's a pension plan is is being
given a pension on your way out for the
rest of your life for for your life
wherever you're going you're going to
wherever you're going for eternity um it
it's it's it's the only thing that you
take with you is what you left behind
and for C it was all about leaving
behind a mark a Mark that of champion
yeah it was attached to Ego we all have
it yeah it was attached to some
selfishness and all but yeah was also
attached to wanting to leave something
great behind yeah to know that you were
part of it that you existed for a reason
that that that you sacrificed for a
reason and
all that freaking pain I brought my
father I was searching for something
yeah I made it into a righteous search I
made it into I did and I made it into it
was okay because it was righteous and I
but it still did
damage it still did damage it still hurt
people it still betrayed my father's
trust
and CZ betrayed mine but he didn't do it
maliciously he he did it out of
again my father came home this is how
I'm going to connect it my father came
home from from work one night 12:00 and
I was waiting up and like I said I was
over 9 10 years old and he got mad at me
he goes go to bed what are you doing up
I said I'm waiting for you waiting for
you and
um he said well go to bed I said no I I
I what were you doing he said I was at
the hospital you were there why were you
there so late you
know he answered me he he said there was
a patient there was a sick patient I
said he must be better now because
you're his doctor you know because my
father could fix
anything my father nothing got in the
way of the truth nothing nothing even
blown his son's
bubble
matter of factly he said to
me uh no he's not going to get better
he's going to
die and
um so as a 9-year-old kid you know
you're a kid you're selfish you know not
in a bad way but you know you want what
you and I said
um I said two things first I said how
how you're his
doctor how it can't be and then I said I
I just said it almost angry then why
were you there like you should have been
here with me yeah and you know what he
said to me cuz you don't give up on
life go to
bed and don't give up on life and that's
I finally connected to dots this idiot
that didn't graduate high
school I finally connected to dots I was
ask CA to give up on
life you don't you don't give up on life
you don't give up on aspirations of life
life is all forms of life doesn't have
to be a physical form of it it's life
it's having a reason to be
alive it's having a reason to have
tomorrow and and C's only reason to have
tomorrow was to have another heavyweight
champ and Teddy Atlas even though we
were together all those years and we
were partners and we trained together
and we would we would you know the only
thing we didn't do was what they did in
the Indian movies where where they cut
the finger and they became Blood
Brothers that's that's the only thing we
didn't do and I felt like we did that
yeah with without cutting
and and now here we are and he freaking
betrayed me just and and um and then all
of a sudden I connected to D I was
like he didn't betray me in the in that
cold
sense he didn't give up on
life uh years later Mike Tyson apologize
to
you what what what's meaningful to you
about that how does that fit the story I
want to be the great gracious guy right
now say oh I'm so hum human that that
you know a man's man enough to say sorry
that's it we're good I want to be really
that that's that's that's the that's the
best presentation of Teddy Atlas I could
put out there he's a good guy he
forgives he he's a good guy he's a he's
a he's a standup guy and he's a good guy
I'm not
sure if he truly did it for himself that
he really did
it because he felt
that
it was
true but but if he's persuaded by other
things he was in the middle I know I'm
taking it too deep I know but what am I
going to do he was in the middle of 12
steps with the you know getting out of
drugs alcohol 12 steps which is a
commemorable thing really it is and and
he's taking the steps and part of the
steps was to admit all to apologize to
all people you offended in
life
okay but
are you doing it for the 12 steps or you
doing it because you
really
truly have come to terms with
believing what you did was that hurtful
to me and that it matters to you that it
was that hurtful to me and that you were
wrong in doing it did you do it for I
know that's deep I know that I'm a
freaking idiot I'm you're you're a Teddy
freaking you're you're you should be
better than that he's better than you
yeah maybe he is better than me maybe he
is really seriously maybe he is and and
I took it he put his hand out I took it
I we hugged he said I love you I I I
yeah
yeah I but I want to
believe but what did cuz tell me no
matter what a man says there what he
does in the end that he intended to do
all along so to this day
today was it really genuine or was it
reflective of that moment for him to get
what he needed to you know for that step
or was it
truly for what I needed to to really
that he really
cared that what he did to me caused me
to do what I did because I did something
that was pretty damn bad to him too is
he able
to deal with that and put that where it
has to be put is he able to put that or
or is it just he did something he had to
do and maybe he's sorry he did it I know
I'm look I appreciate it that
he I would have rather been in a private
place yeah so for people don't know you
were in the middle of commentating a
fight and he walked up from behind you
and he said he was sorry he shook your
hand gave you a hug I didn't know he
said I love you yeah he's emotional I
get emotional a little bit too but but
he he's emotional and he can be and he
can be I can see why people have a
Fascination in a love affair with him
right now because he
was because you know he
was he was the meteor the meteor that
went across the sky that is if they
didn't see it their parents told him
about it there was a media that came
across the sky one day and and and the
media is walking around in the room now
and that's meteorite and then and it
actually landed here and and that's it
right there and and and now he's come a
long way and now he's you know he's more
human and and he he's lovable you know
and and compassionate and he cries and
and I get the fascin I get the love
affair I get it because we're inherently
we're people that want to forgive we're
people that we want to be good we and
part of being good is to forgive people
and to to show show compassion to people
and so and when somebody's been
damaged uh to acknowledge they've been
damaged to acknowledge that you know
they've been damaged and you care about
them being damaged and how do you show
care through admiration you know in in
some ways almost through adol and he's
getting adol from people like you know
uh which is to an incredible level and
it's it's a phenomena but but I get it I
understand it and
um I don't know if he gets it I don't
know if underneath all of this he's a
complex guy he's a sensitive guy I don't
know and I am too yeah and one complex
guy talking about another complex guy I
don't know if Underneath It All where
he's really truly at as far as that day
that he said that to me is there part of
you that's sorry to Mike for not sorry
yeah and that's listen that's fair I I
know dimensions of human nature too well
to not know that he still has to have
certain because I have those strong
feelings what it's not fair for him to
have him damn right it's
fair now now he could look at it if if
he was to be held to his word that night
that he just acknowledges that what
happened he deserved because of what he
you know the position he put me in and
he put himself in what he did and I
wouldn't change nothing you know still
you're you don't regret pulling the gun
on him I regret that I had to yeah yeah
I regret very much that that I had to
that I regret very much he crossed the
line I hated him for putting me in that
position that that you know how dare he
think that that somebody's feelings are
that
trivial that the way I would feel about
myself and the way the girl would feel
about herself that was 11 years old at
the time how she would feel about
herself how how dare that he think it's
that trivial that you
know that I shouldn't be ready to
freaking to both die and kill for that
yeah why didn't custom
a see it in a deeper way and talk
through it did the word came back to me
but of course what does it
mean but the word came back to me that C
said you were right but if he took the
side of Teddy he would destroy a
potentially a great a great fighter why
why do you think that okay if you were
to try to understand the point he was
making why why is that true is isn't the
part of greatness that you said is
building the character of knowing what
is right what you know CU was afraid to
to go there where he used to not be
afraid
because it's kind of like you're never
afraid of going up and I I get it you
know when I train to fight an hour if I
come out of retirement I train to fight
an hour I feel in Camp like I'm I feel
like I'm on death row every day that
that if every day I I try to retrace my
memory and say did I feel this way when
I was younger I I don't remember feeling
this way I feel every day a dreadful
feeling that if I don't get this right I
I I've betrayed everything I betrayed
the Fighter's trust I betrayed uh what
I'm supposed to be and then one one day
I tried to figure it out why do I feel
this way it's so intense I was in Camp
for two months training a guy for the
world title couple few years ago um
fighting the hardest puncher in the
world at the time and um adona Stevenson
and the fighter was Ukrainian and I was
you know brought in to train him for
that fight and he trusted me and changed
his whole style Trust to me mhm oh my
God I went to bed every night like
praying um dread waking up dread my
stomach down to here every saying what
what if I fail him what what what if
everything that I told him was going to
happen don't happen what if I fail him
what what if he trusted me and I I
betrayed that trust and the thing was
the with cus was you know he used to be
stronger than that and then I tried to
figure out why I got this way and why it
was so Dreadful to me and why I felt
like I was on death row every day
trading to fighter like did I do enough
did I do right well well will we
accomplish what we well we accomplish
what I promised him we would accomplish
what I keep my word and and then I
started thinking what how did I become
this weak how did I freaking become I
was a pretty strong freaking guy how did
I become this weak and then finally I
think I figured it out you know why
because I was always working to get up
but once I finally got up now I was
looking down and I finally hit me I said
I didn't want to lose I said there was
nothing to lose on my way up mhm now all
of a sudden there's something to lose
when you're up there and you're looking
down and that's where he was and that's
where CU was cuz cuz was at the end of
his rle he he was he accomplished the
two World Champs all the stuff right
everything he and and and he did it
right now all of a sudden it wasn't
about moving forward it was about
falling
down holy cow I was like I got it cus I
got it I got it you didn't want to fall
down oh my God you didn't want to fall
and he this was his last
chance you don't give up on life this
was his last chance to live
forever to to make everything he did
worthwhile to have the youngest heav it
wasn't just heavyweight J you got to
remember MH he was the youngest
heavyweight champ ever and to have that
it was okay to die now
and how's
loyalty to someone named Teddy Atlas
gonna get in the way of that that's a
tital wave that there ain't no war
that's been made high enough to stop
that title wave and now I'll stop
myself yeah there
is MH but but it have to be an awful big
one and you know what who are we to say
that we could ever Build That Wall that
big who is any of Who Am might just say
do you think if you were to put yourself
in the shoes of C cust
tomato can you see yourself having the
big enough wall where you would choose
loyalty now if I answer the way I feel I
then then I'm you know I'm making myself
John Wayne again you don't have to
answer then I think
loyalty loyalty is important no matter
what a man says it's what he does in the
end that he intends to do do all along I
didn't make that up cussed and and when
when this all went
down those words came freaking echoing
into my freaking ears I didn't want them
cotton doesn't
help and they freaking kept coming into
my ears and what do you think still an
immature kid at the time
you know I was young still an immature
kid at the time what the freak do you
think my response was you were full
of yeah and but I got past that do you
do you forgive C have you found
forgiveness listen I forgive him
because he gave me more than he took
away from me
mhm if I can what kind of man am I if I
can at least acknowledge that and be
grateful for that he I he he gave me
more than he took from me and um I'm
grateful for that I'm also grateful for
what I gave him that I had you know that
I I did give him
something and um at that point in his
life you know
uh a
place a place to
still to still have test tubes and um
chemistry experiments you know a
laboratory where you could still create
great fighter and I I helped give him
that I helped I helped I was part of
that lab and making sure that lab was
there and um just that there was the
existence of test tubes um in the place
because you can't freaking do
experiments without test tubes now
you're the scientist with the test tubes
yeah I I I guess so and um I I just hope
that um um what I said earlier is is
really is really my thread through this
whole thing when you say can you forgive
cuss
um
I I'm still trying to forgive
myself
and if if I can have hope that I can
forgive myself I think that hope has to
start with the power to forgive someone
else
how can I ever forgive myself for all my
failings and figure it out if I can't
start and practice
it by forgiving someone else for some
shortcomings and for
me that's that's that's the only sense
of sometimes a very hard thing to make
sense
of that that that's my Nord star
that's that's my compass CU used to make
me laugh you know me and him did
everything together we drive and we get
lost in the city we get lost in a bron
and he get all frustrated and he said
Atlas you're a great trainer but you
turn you around you spin you around and
you're lost and I said me or we and
because I was the only one who would
argue with him and and it was really
funny sometime and I said we or me you
we are he goes I don't get cuz you're
lost I'm lost what are you talking about
and then all of a sudden CZ couldn't
give in he just couldn't admit he
couldn't give in you know what he said
to me all of a sudden he goes when I was
in the Army if I had a compass I could
get out of the woods I said we're not in
the woods we're not in Army we don't
have a compass cuz
cuz
just don't argue with me I one time
we're driving I want I want to get back
to CCO we we just finished at the Bronx
it's been a long day yeah you know
visiting the the murderers Inc uh houses
and everything else that that he took me
through for the 1800 time and um and he
would fall asleep you know he was
getting older and he and he would just
fall asleep in the car so what do you
think I went a little faster right
because before he went to sleep he said
don't speed mhm so I don't consider
myself
I try to be an honest guy I try to be a
freaking but yeah you know it was a five
or six guys what did I say earlier try
to do less submitting yeah really in all
faces try to submit a little less try to
lie a little less today MH a little less
try to get stronger try to get a little
better M so here we are and we're driv
and all of a sudden he's I what did I do
80 75 probably yeah probably
did you know whatever and um all of a
sudden he wakes
up you were speeding oh I lie no I
wasn't don't
lie I'm not
Li you lied again you
speeding now come on this guy he's you
know what I mean he's
he's he's unbelievable so I got to
figure you know he's the he he's David
Copperfield I want to know the trick
yeah I want to know how he freaking he
made this thing
disappear so I said what are you talking
how do you know he goes cuz I timed you
I looked at the post number and I'm like
what I looked at the post number on the
side of the road where we were whatever
miles that and and I never knew they
even existed yeah I look and I said yeah
there's Little Numbers he started timing
fell asleep yeah he timed it and he look
he goes we couldn't have got from here
to there in that amount of time unless
you were going 75 miles hour and I'm
like all right I'm smart man all right
I'm impressed you don't try to get the
mile the mile per hour part right it's
enough that you got me yeah yeah that's
enough
I'm yeah I said and I'm not going to do
that no I'm you know and and just he
helped me in crazy ways where there
would be times where I wanted to be you
know where you wanted to be whatever
right convenient weak submit right and
then all of a
sudden all of a sudden CZ in my mind cus
was there with the
stopwatch and and I'd be like you
know uh no you know where I was about to
say yes to whatever that yeah
particular situation
was
somebody up there
call
hell
hello yes doing great thank
you just for the record never had a
phone call like this it's hotel security
the question is he asked me is are you
okay sir are you okay are we okay I
think
so I I think so so far yeah you know I
can go like so far it's kind of like
that old joke you know where the guy
jumps off the Empire State Building he's
falling down and he's going you know
80th floor 70th floor 60th floor 50 he
gets past the 50th floor and they're
look at him out the window and he goes
how am I doing so far so good I I don't
know where it's going to end but um so
uh Mike Tyson is considered by many to
be one of the great boxers one of the
greatest boxers of all time heavyweight
boxers
uh what do you think on the positive
side made him great I don't know he was
ever
great I know he was
Sensational I know he was the greatest
mix of maybe speed and power
ever I know he was one of the greatest
punches from either side of the plate
left or right there's been great punches
with just the right hand like Ernie
Shavers and Deontay Wilder and Max bear
I don't know if there's ever been anyone
who could punch as good as he did on
either side with either hand other than
Joe Lewis and a few others I don't know
if there's ever been such a combination
of speed and power to that pure level
that he had and it was a pure level I
don't know if there was ever as good a
fighter as Tyson was where maybe one
night he was great where he wasn't
tested but he might have been ready to
be tested that one night against Michael
Springs when he took him apart 90
seconds I think I saw a great fighter
that night
I don't think you can be great unless
you have
all the requirements of being great what
does it take to be a great
fighter truly
great to not rely on someone's else's
weakness to be
strong to be strong on your own too
often he relied on other people's
weakness whether it's the by being
intimidated or whether is because his
talent was so much greater than there
that it was like putting a monster truck
in there with the Volkswagen and the
Volkswagen was going to get crushed no
matter how much horsepower the
Volkswagen might have had under the hood
and you put under the
hood it was going to get crushed the
monster truck was not going to allow it
to be a contest
and to be able to find a way when your
talent wasn't enough he didn't find a
way when his talent wasn't enough and he
and I'm not making statements if I'm not
ready to put some evidence you know like
if we were in a courtroom exhibit a um
when he fought when he fought Buster
Douglas um Buster Douglas matched his
will and didn't get intimidated stood up
to him he didn't do what most people did
he didn't submit even a little bit not
that night he had in the past but in
that night he didn't why because Buster
had Buster had a secret weapon that
night his
mother buz's mother had died a few
months previous he loved his mother very
much bua had always had Talent big
heavyweight talented could punch
technically
solid he was all those things always was
but he quit in fights he he he did less
than he should have done he never lived
up to his ability he gave in he
submitted he wasn't strong enough he
never had a reason to be strong enough
when his mother died he had a reason
nothing could hurt him as much as his
mother dying hurt him Mike Tyson
included that night Mike
Tyson could not hurt him as much as his
mother had hurt him by dying that night
he had a reason to be strong for his
mother and he was strong he was
everything he was supposed to be and
more and he stood up to Mike and Mike
for the first time maybe ever was in a
fight where he had to overcome something
where he had to be more than talented
more than a
puncher more than a guy with
scintillating
speed and he wasn't and then that night
got followed by another Knight with
Holyfield Holyfield wasn't as talented
as him as big as M
puncha but
Holyfield had the
character he was strong in ways that
Tyson wasn't strong he was strong in a
way
where he could find a way he was willing
to find a way he's willing to go to the
cliff to to truly die before he
submitted you know a lot of stuff is
just wor yeah they're GNA have to carry
me out on the shield yeah sure sure okay
yeah until it comes time to be carried
out on the shield sometimes there's
people that actually mean it MH
you think Mike didn't have that well all
right he let's just say arbitrarily I
don't have his Reon for me let's say he
was 55 and five I know he had about five
losses all right let's say he was 55 and
five right a lot of
Knockouts I have a saying a fight's not
a fight until there's something to
overcome until then it's just an
athletic uh exhibition contest yeah
who's a better athlete who's got more
quick twitch fibers who's who who's more
developed who's in better this who's
who's more developed than those physical
areas but a fight is not a fight until
there's something to overcome
okay so if you go by my definition not
Websters my definition which I think
means
something M Tyson was only in five
fights in his
life the five fights where there was
something to overcome
and he didn't overcome it now I know
people hate me for this including
Tyson I I understand hate me oh you're a
hater because you weren't with him you
didn't make the money because this
because that because you got
betrayed I think I'm better than that I
hope I'm better than that I believe I'm
better than that I'm not a hater i' I've
broadcast fights for 25 years on ESPN
where there was some people in the
corner I did not like and if they did
did a good job this guy's doing a great
job and then there were guys that I
liked and I had friendship he he he he
messed up and we weren't friends no
more friendship got to be tested
remember that so we weren't friends no
more but why did I do that because it
was my
job it was more important for
me when when it's all over with the only
thing you're left with
is I mean we're going to be dust all of
us right the only thing we're left with
is what carries on our
reputation you know Legacy whatever that
is but our reputation that's all we're
left with and that's all our kids are
left
with I wanted to be as good as it can be
I've always had a ability I've done a
lot of things wrong and I've had a lot
of
lackings but the one strength I've had
if I had a strength
is to understand
somehow through osmosis I guess to learn
the
lesson that was
important is not what's in front of you
for those 5 seconds for that moment in
life it's what's left behind you when
those 5 seconds are gone when that what
whatever it is that you're dealing with
you know whatever the that moment is
whatever that moment what you do in that
moment the action of that moment is
going to stay with
you and be you it's going to become
you what what you face for that
moment it's
gone it's it's gone in the air in an
instant it's gone it's done whether you
take whether you stand up there and you
get shot in the head and the guy
freaking blows your brains out or you
freaking you you stand up or you're
fighting a guy who's like an un a scary
guy to fight but you fight him and you
beat him or he beats you up
but how
you represented
yourself in that moment
is all that matters D's going to live
what happened don't
matter it don't matter that you guys
shot in the head I know that sounds
absurd but if you believe that it was
important to stand up and had take the
chance to get shot in the freaking head
rather than to live like an empty
vessel you know
what that's all that freaking matters
and somehow that got freaking wrapped
into this freaking head of mine like
like that's what matters that's all that
matters you know how many times I went
and I I the were things whether it was
with this one with Tyson with that I
didn't want to be there I was scared to
death but I was more
scared I was more scared living with
regret how I would have felt yeah I
don't want to be in solitary confinement
the rest of my life with that freaking
guy in the cell next to me called regret
I don't freaking want to be next to that
guy if I want to freaking go down that
road I'll watch papon you know what I
mean and and I get my feel from that but
I don't want to freaking live it I'm
afraid of what my children would think
of me if if I fail in those
areas why
because that's forever when I'm closing
my eyes for the last time I I don't want
to have that fear I don't want to have
that fear you know whether I'm going
down there or whether I'm going up there
you know I I I laugh because uh I I I
was I was around guys years ago that
used to when we talk about that you know
in just you know and um I we get a kick
out of this this one guy who' been
around the block a few times um when he
say hey Teddy I ain't worried about that
I got friends in both
places that's a good line and I yeah and
I thought it was a I thought it was good
uh listen Mike Tyson you want me to say
he was a great fighter then you want me
to betray what I really you know what I
mean you want me to do that I ain't
doing it for listen I could do it to be
a biger Teddy Atlas and I know it would
work for me I I know it would be it do
great promotional work for me I know it
would it would make me more popular in
certain area I know it I'm not that dumb
not that dumb but I also know what else
it would do to
me and I don't want it to do that to me
I think he was a great talent I think
maybe the night with Michael Spinx maybe
the M Night with M maybe he could have
been that fighter maybe he could but he
didn't never really get tested but he
might have been ready no matter what I
have to be tested that night that's how
good he was that's how even though it
was a guy who used to be a light
heavyweight I get it but it was still a
guy who beat Larry Holmes who still had
something left uh Michael Spinx so and a
great puncher um and an Olympic gold
medalist but and a special fighter one
of the great light heavyweights of all
time you know what Mike Tyson was he was
a meteor he was a meteor that struck
across and not too many meteors and we
still talk about himh and and and unlike
H's comment he came back and and he's
walking around and he's he has become
greater after his career more loved more
beloved more AED and he's been forgiven
he found the Fountain of forgiveness I
don't know I wish I could find that
where he has been forgotten for all his
shortcomings all the things that he may
have done may not have done we don't
know only him and God
know but he's been forgiven of all that
and he's been not only
forgiven he's rised above it and and
above that and been brought above that
he's been brought to the pyramids of of
of the greatest athletes that that in
the world and in every in every way in
every way as a person as a fighter as a
historian yeah as a
figure as a celebrity I mean even a
philosopher everything yeah so I will
take it back all right all you guys out
there you forgive me he's the greatest
of all time if you encapsulate all that
if you encapsulate everything I just
tried to describe um and explain if you
put that all he's the greatest of all
time yeah he is but he still might be 0
and5 in know record of 55 fights he
might in Teddy Alice's
book again I got friends in both places
so it's okay wherever I go I I have
company somebody there will like me this
despite me saying this he might be on
fight because of five fights where there
was something to overcome which really
defines a fight he came he he didn't
find the
way let me ask Teddy Atlas to introspect
on the human nature here it's part of
the complexities of your feelings on
this whole thing is that you know the
some degree that if you were coaching
Mike Tyson he could be truly great
throughout know Co I'm going to cut you
right off because you asked a million
dollar question I wish you didn't but
you did you did because that's why when
do I get paid that's why you get paid I
get it you took the words out of my
mouth that's why you are where you
are and that's why I'm
here the humility I'm gonna I'm gonna
Again full disclosure it's important
right um I'm going to cheat I'm going to
take some of ca's wisdom
all right a little bit of mine
yeah um cuz told somebody
that if Teddy Atlas got his way he might
have been a better person but we would
have risked him not being a great
fighter now I believe and I thought cus
did and I think he did up to that point
in his life that part of your strength
of character made you a great Fighter um
and truly a great fighter and part of
that battle to be a better person that
that fight if you will to be a better
person to overcome the themes to be a
better person um part of that fire you
have to go through to be a better
person I really truly bought into it and
I and I'm in for
life that is really the only way to be a
great fighter
and I don't think that's what cus
meant I thought he meant I think he
meant that cus knew more than I did of
what was about to come and what would
come and what the world was how people
would try to steal him how people would
take them how people would steal his
guy the last thing he had to
really the thing that he lived for
because he lived to have another
heavyweight champ
the greatest fighter ever CZ and C's
mine he could be and I believe that CZ
knew that
he he could put forward a guy that had
the ability to be the greatest fighter
ever without fully completing the
mission of what it takes to really be
great but that he wouldn't he wouldn't
be around to have to witness
it and that he
wouldn't he was willing he would oh man
this is
awful he's willing to concede that he
might be dead in order to have eternal
life in order to have greatness uh and
which CU does have greatness and part of
that greatness is attached to Tyson and
he deserves it he deserves it C was a
great
man and I wouldn't be here partly
without him but that was part of the
calculation I know that's deep but I
know that's oh God I hate myself right
now
know but
um but cuz he knew he was getting out
free he knew he was GNA not have to be
there he was he was getting off easy oh
Teddy how do you say someone's gonna be
dead they getting off easy well I say it
again in case you didn't hear me all
right he he he was going to get off easy
and not have to face where he came up
short because he did his job because he
put forward the greatest fight of all
time and you guys screwed it up and he
knew that that might happen but you guys
screwed it up and and whatever that's
your fault that's on I tell you Tyson
will be mad at this but that's on
Tyson how could you say that Teddy he
loved me I'm not saying he didn't love
you but he loved him he loved some other
stuff too and I don't know if Tyson
could ever come to Griff's light with
that and and it's not his job to but
it's my job not to hide from it I know
cin Dimensions that other people
just only think they know did cus know
did cus know this about
himself they did he reflected he
introspected well he sent a message to
me c sent a guy to me my wife was
pregnant we were living in apartment
apartment and Cat on C skill road we
went through all this I you know and I
was getting ready to move to Staten
Island and we still were there for a
little while before we did you know
after all this went
down he sent a guy to me to the house
secret whatever you want to call it my
wife
me
so I listen to
him cuz said if you leave I'm I'm a
messenger you know whatever if you
leave this was in a aftermath of what
the gun the whole thing you gota
remember Tyson was Award of the state he
was put in C's custody cuz was looking
to adopt him for obvious reason so he
had control and and he loved
him how dare I say anything less I
won't but it made sense too but he was
Award of the state still do you know
what that means there's
rules means the state's still
overlooking it mhm if he living the
right life you
know you got to remember he came out of
you know he came out of of a
jail so reform school but if he ain't
living like he could be taken away from
CZ what's not living the right life well
he he wasn't in school no more they
didn't know about it um he he had some
things that were going on we won't get
into that right now in school and
different things
whatever and he had his trainer put a
gun to his head that is so good
if a report came back to them that that
happened he would have been taken away
from
cus that couldn't happen nobody knows
this I talk about a little bit but never
probably because why would I I don't
know why am I doing it now I don't know
because I don't know because I am
because it's now because it's now maybe
maybe because it's now I don't know so
he sent this
man that you know obviously we both knew
and he said here's the deal Teddy if no
talk about this wants it to you know
disappear basically you
leave and he will give you 5% his word
can you imagine he would he will give
you 5% of Tyson's earnings for the rest
of his
career and um but I don't regret it one
bit because it wouldn't have happened
anyway see that's where I I could be
honest with my people say oh stand up
guy because I told told him shove it
with the you
know you know to in that place and and
um and tell cuz to shove it in that
freaking play you know I was man um
Teddy Teddy don't get angry don't get
angry are you out of you serious get out
of here tell them to go shove it
over and you know my wife was like huh
but and then people like after why
didn't you take the deal it wasn't a
deal it was Escape
clause for cuss it was it was a it was
an insurance policy that his you know
that this kid wouldn't be taken away
from and thank God he wasn't I wasn't
going to go and say nothing they didn't
have to worry about cuz forgot who I was
cuz forgot why he went to court for me
because of those because of those
characteristics that he said he loved
and he noticed and that that he
admired I didn't lose those character he
forgot that that was me he forgot who he
was talking to he didn't have to do
that how about that's why I told him to
shove it up his not because of the other
insult yeah and then and then when
people said to me oh you would stand up
because it was around a little bit it
was around in the circles and then were
people oh stand up Teddy he he didn't
care about the money I said stand up
Teddy what are you talking about how how
about how about just realistic Teddy how
about I live in a real world that I was
never going to get that money so I'm
saying I'm standing up to something that
I knew never existed so I ain't stand up
not in that way I am in other ways maybe
but not don't don't put a metal on my
chest for that because because that
never existed yeah it was never meant to
exist but he didn't even understand that
was the one thing that that really
disappointed me and cuss I was like cuz
you really allowed this to get to you
where where you where you've allowed it
to really fog up your thinking to the
point where you're smarter than that
you're better than that that you would
actually think you got a freaking offer
me a
freaking pieces of silver yeah you
really think that that's what you freak
you like all that you told me that you
love me and that we I was the young
master and that all this and and you
think you were going to buy
me and I was going to and that was going
to keep me quiet how about I would keep
quiet because I would always keep
quiet so he thought maybe you might
betray him isn't that interesting
yeah and why did he think that no no
really fear yeah but yeah fear is the at
the essence of everything is it
connected with everything fear of losing
what he was going to lose but it was
more than fear
it was him not believing in the things
that he told me he believed
in he didn't even know
that he believed in me because I was a
standup guy because I because I didn't
sell myself because because I you know I
didn't freaking turn evidence I I didn't
make a deal I didn't do and and that's
why he went to court that's why he stood
up for me and I appreciate it and that
was what he lived by and that was his
you know those were the blocks of being
man oh so much for those
blocks well it's like you said
loyalty requires uh you know he would
have had to take a
risk on losing immortality that he would
achieve by creating that's the
only 100% but the only way you ever find
out if somebody is that it's hard it's
the test yeah and it was cut this is
Shakespearean you know the story C told
me C said and it does come in different
forms yeah I said all right cuz this was
his test and and some people pass this
test because they're able to pass that
test because it's not really a test not
for them because it doesn't speak to
their weakness but it's the test that
speaks to the weakness that's the
one so this one I get it I get what it
spoke to cuz and you know what at the
end of the day I forgive
you and I feel bad for
you I feel bad that you were put in that
position after you lived your life that
way and that you that you taught that
and you preach that from the mountain
tops that that you had to
be that you had to
be I'm not going to use the word
but that that you had to fail yourself
and that you had to somehow know that
before you died I just pray that you
didn't know that and you still don't
know that because you were great you are
great and um and you've given me
some you know you're giving me some
to to Aspire
towards to try
to try to be less
weak try to be
better and try to be as good as
you wanted to
be I wish I can
someday more importantly I I wish I
could make my
father you
know feel um
just feel good up
there